hi
everybody
welcome to the sag award
thank you
um okay so squid game took
everyone by storm
it was
i mean i can't even describe the fervor
about this show how excited are you all
to be here tonight being nominated and
being nominees
like
it's so great especially because we're
all here together as a group and i
really want to extend our thanks to sag
after for letting us be here
now listen
you are still with us
you all not so much any possibility
season two we can get flashbacks or
anything can you come back anyone yeah i
think jj has a so good idea okay that's
the idea let's hear the idea
uh
mask many
so my idea is that maybe the masked men
took all of them and made sure they came
back to life i love it
i love it i'm in i'm in i i do want to
ask you be nominated tonight
individually as an actor what does that
mean to you
uh
[Music]
it's truly such a huge honor i never
imagined that this day would come and
it's especially you know i cannot
believe that i'm going to be there along
with all of the stars that i saw on
screen and was just in awe of i love
that i got to come over to you too and
ask you the same thing oh
be nominated individually tonight how
exciting is this for you
it is such an honor it's just
describable undescribable feeling i
can't even
i don't know i really don't know i
couldn't digest yet
is there someone here tonight that you
just have to meet
rhys read this one
reese witherspoon okay you heard that
rhys we gotta make that happen we've
gotta make that
love it so much before i let you guys go
i know that you were a model before you
look gorgeous tonight louis vuitton yes
okay tell me about this dress uh nicola
made
for tonight and today
and you know this is actually like
korean traditional hairstyle and then i
asked them to make we call it thingy
yeah so what does peng what does pengy
mean tengi dengue what is dengue it's
like the style of the hair right
hairstyle yeah it's the name of the yeah
yeah thingy is the is the name dengue
yeah
okay
yeah
i'm trying i'm trying you're great
you're great well we're all huge fans of
the series i like your idea i want you
all back season two
absolutely congratulations on everything
i think it's gonna be a big night for
you guys tonight good luck to you
[Music]